we begin this hour with a look at how
social media and cell phones can affect
children it's part of our coverage of
mental health awareness month a recent
survey showed 43 of kids between ages 8
and 12 have smartphones that number
soars to 88 for kids between 13 and 18.
and on average those teens spend nearly
one and a half hours per day on social
media sites we wanted to have an honest
conversation with a group of kids about
everything from the pressure of owning a
phone to expectations created by social
media we spoke to sam nane ellie tiara
aaron and jade all have cell phones
except for name he's only eight years
old and all are on at least one social
media platform
did you feel pressure
to
need a cell phone because other people
had it
yeah for sure it was one of those things
where all of my friends had them so i
kept asking and asking
i did feel pressured because in fifth
grade literally every single one of my
classmates had a phone at that time
i definitely was pressured it was like a
competition to see who would get a phone
first when i was in the fifth grade have
you ever felt separation anxiety when
you didn't have your phone in your hand
or you didn't have access to it in the
past few years it was like
when i would get my phone taken i'd be
like oh i miss my phone what am i going
to do now
felt like i couldn't live without it
i've definitely felt it like i know my
friends have like taken my phone when i
was younger and i would always get a
little nervous about like where's my
phone like that was the only thing on my
mind when they took it like
i feel that i'm missing like quote
unquote a part of me i think i realize
how impatient i've gotten when i don't
have it and i can't fill up
the time with
games or social media or things like
that and you're just like oh
just stand and look around
pretty bored right now
okay um name
now you don't have a phone but you have
access to
an ipad
yeah games
switch when you don't have those things
and you don't have access how do you
feel i also mentioned a part of me like
erin says
the main way you guys
hang out quote unquote with your friends
outside of school
social media
outside of school me and my friends we
do a lot of like
voice calls a lot and we play games and
we like do study calls and we probably
do that for a good amount of time
maybe
i think this weekend we probably spent
like 15 hours on call
over the course of the weekend yeah okay
all right nine have you been playing
video games or or got lost on youtube
and just been watching video after video
after video i can't tell just hours the
only thing i would say
want to watch if no one tells me
now you can't watch that right
youtube youtube youtube tiara what about
you
i would say i'm on tick tock two to
three hours two to three hours straight
shot on tick tock yeah
just sitting there scrolling yeah what's
so interesting about tick tock
just seeing like different people
just make funny videos it's like
and the fact that i can relate to the
videos it just makes me want to watch
more and more and more you're on youtube
or tick tock snapchat
discord but i feel like
there could be a darker side to that am
i right by saying that definitely that
comparison thing that you do when you're
scrolling and you see all these
different people you constantly compare
yourself and i think that's definitely a
negative and it always seems like
they're living the perfect life that you
are not even though that's not true
no i agree with what ellie said like it
acts like they have a perfect client and
they're perfect they can do whatever
they want they have all that money
compared to them i'm a nobody i like art
a lot i
draw in my free time and i write in my
free time and then i see like all these
content creators making like these
gorgeous gorgeous pieces of art
digitally and they're like younger than
me there could be like 12 and they
already like mastered the use of like
lighting and shading and i'm looking at
this and i'm like holy crap like why am
i doing this so there's so many other
people that are like so much younger
than me and have so much more potential
than me basically social media is
everyone's persona and it's not actually
like how they are but it's like rather
how they present themselves so it's like
hard for someone who sees that to like
realize that that's maybe not their life
isn't as good as it seems yeah now let
me ask you something
when you were on youtube
during
certain things that were happening in
this country did you see certain things
that impacted you yes i'm like
what are are these police doing like
they willing you talking about police
and brutality
yes what was that like when you saw
stuff like that
well i saw so it's like that i'm
thinking that we're not even out of
slavery anymore like we're back
where we were
when times
started you're eight years old and you
were thinking that yes i was concerned
for myself because
i'm black
and
these
people are like disrespecting us
are my kind and like
i'm not i'm not feeling good about that
my final question is
social media is
a great platform for some people but a
bad platform for others tiara social
media is what you make it
it depends on what you allow yourself to
see who you follow who you don't follow
what's on your explore page it's just
what you make it
ellie i was gonna say social media is
its own world
it definitely is oh boy and my advice to
them afterwards um
don't get lost in that world yeah exist
in this real world and tap into people
that can speak encouragement and give
you light and the right energy because
sometimes being on social media and
getting lost in it can be depleting to
these young kids they seem to understand
that though that i was impressed with
naim because he's eight but all the age
ranges were saying what you see
sometimes is not reality they at least
seem to be aware of that were they they
are savvy they they were yeah they were
savvy as a warrior i also explained to
them that as adults we struggle with the
same thing yeah we watch a commercial
and we're sitting here looking at some
guy with a fancy car and a ton of money
absolutely we immediately say i want to
buy this product because i see this guy
doing that and women do the same thing
that's how they market to us so i just
love the fact that they are realizing
this and having this hyper awareness
that they engage yeah i would wonder if
they think they're getting more out of
social media or social media is getting
more out of them and if they could they
could wish it away you know would they
rather live in a world without it yeah
or do they prefer it this way it's
really good i know my vote is world
without it without it but i'm a foggy
now welcome to your 40s nate